foreign
good afternoon everyone uh just before I
read out the prayers today can you
please join me in putting our thoughts
and prayers for those experiencing the
impacts of cyclone Gabriel
um and the citizens involved but also to
our colleagues showing great fortitude
and Leadership during this national
state of emergency
today I'll be doing the Maori prayer to
open and an English one to close
foreign
[Music]
please be seated
foreign
information the public gallery and to
reiterate to councilors and staff
um we will be switching around the
agenda slightly so
since they're 18 Again items on this
agenda I've decided it's best to discuss
the agenda items with the most public
and counselor attention first and the
environment self and presentation has
been postponed to a further date
so the order will go as follow after the
presentation from active Southland item
five we were then move to terms of
reference which is item 10 and then fly
on to item 11 and 12. from there we'll
move on to the bridge slash waterpro
pipe discussion item 14 and then from
there we will flick to the annual report
item 17 and finally we'll flick back to
item seven and follow the order from
there
um
which should hopefully mean that we
won't tire out as quickly
are there any apologies today I think
everyone around the room is here
second uh Declarations of conflicts of
interest are there any on this agenda
no
uh minutes of meetings uh so first of
all we will do the minutes of the
ordinary meeting of the gore District
Council held on the Tuesday 13th of
December
do we have any questions for governance
support on these minutes
foreign
do I have a mover that these minutes are
true and correct
councilor mechanel and a seconder
councilor Havel
I will put the motion all those in favor
please say aye against the motion is
carried
for the minutes of the ordinary meeting
of the gore District Council held on
Tuesday the 24th of January 2023 do we
have any questions for the government's
miniature on these minutes
no can I have a mover for uh that these
questions that these minutes are true
and correct
uh we had a question
there is one error in that it says
Tuesday the 24th of January 2022.
thank you for that counselor uh do we
have a mover uh councilor garden and a
signature
councilor Dixon
uh I will put the motion all those in
favor please say aye
against the motion is carried
do we have any urgent late business
Suite we will move into
the first presentation by active
Southland we've got a representative
around
feel free to come to the front
foreign
thank you so much for the opportunity to
share with you
um on behalf of the murihikai collective
about our Mahi to create a good food
road map for murihiku Southland so I'll
just take a moment to introduce myself
and the others that are here so I'm
Rochelle Francis I work in the healthy
families and the Cargill team at active
Southland and we facilitate the murihiku
kai Collective
and we have some other Chi Collective
members that are here today so maybe
should I just I'll Stand Up and
introduce yourselves come on
foreign
and we also have an active Southland
team member here in support
nice to see you again
um so the mudahiku kai Collective is a
group comprised of community leaders and
people active in the local food system
that was formed a few years back now to
fill a gap where we saw that there
wasn't a kind of coordinated effort to
to move on issues in our food system and
it comprises a range of different
organizations
and but we won't go into a lot of depth
about the collective today because it's
a whole nother subject we're just going
to focus on the Strategic piece that
we've been working on
so
oh
anything just
okay so the good food road map
um in August last year we facilitated a
one-day co-design workshop with around
70 participants from across Southland
um including local food producers and
suppliers manafinoa kopapa Maori
Services Social and Health agencies food
relief people working in education
social Enterprise and Southern Institute
of Technology Environmental Management
tutors and students Community
organizations volunteers Coin South
elected government local government
representatives and MP local and
Regional Council staff Garden to table
and people with lived experience of food
poverty so as you can tell quite a broad
selection of people
and we utilize this strategic framework
the good food roadmap which was
developed by Healthy Families South
Auckland and the southern initiative
which is a an initiative to address
social economic issues in South Auckland
and this strategic framework is being
adopted and used in a variety of
settings across New Zealand to help
bring people together and have them work
effectively to address issues in our
food system so I've
supplied a copy of this framework
through Susan and encourage you to take
the time to look over it I believe we
did also Supply it to the Gould District
Council when the murihiku kai Collective
submitted on your long-term plan two or
three years back
so in our co-design Workshop Weber's
began by asking people to share their
vision for a food system for Southland
and some key themes emerge which was
summarized in this slide for you so in
essence participants want food to be
affordable and accessible to our whole
Community while supporting health of
people and the planet and sustaining a
strong local economy which I'm sure is a
vision that we can all share invite into
so participants in this co-design
Workshop spent some time exploring the
burning issues and it was clear that our
community is very concerned about how
difficult it is for people to access
good food and believe that action is
needed to address problems in our food
system so burning issues that came up
include
poor access and affordability of good
food versus unhealthy fast food food
waste lack of diversity and locally
grown foods and the need for more
Growers Reliance on National and
international distribution chains with
our local food system trying to compete
with a supermarket chewopoly issues
around land use water soil health and
escalating impacts of climate change and
a lack of regional strategy and
Collective approach to addressing the
root causes
so we gathered our participants around
those five ideals and the good food rep
good food roadmap strategic framework
which are food Equity food sovereignty
food culture and traditions food for
health and well-being and food
resilience and the beauty of using the
Strategic framework is that everyone can
connect with at least one of these five
ideals and they can see how the
particular area of Interest connects
with the broad vision of a flourishing
local food system this is the power of
the framework to bring people together
and help them work collaboratively
so because each of these ideals needs to
be worked together in tandem as part of
an overarching strategy and action plan
to achieve our big picture goal
so in the breakout groups on the day of
the co-design workshop our community
members identified a range of strengths
and resources that exist in our
community to support or challenge these
five ideals
um
sorry a range of strengths resources and
challenges in relation to each of these
five ideals
um and then
we dedicated a focused time for Workshop
participants to to dream and ask how
might we how might we utilize the
resources that exist in our community to
address the challenges and there are a
range of ideas put forward
um
which we've just summarized a wee
selection of those here
Regional Chi coordinator
food Hub South and Kai Commons which is
basically around growing food and public
spaces and these are still in rough
concept stage but we're highlighting
them as kind of um discussion starters
conversation status
um one group actually spent some time
refining an idea for a regional
chi-coordinator and
um this would be a particular interest
to you because there are similar roles
that exist located in local government
that can support
a flourishing local food system however
our participants in the workshop really
wanted to see this role um
uh taken into the murihiku kai
Collective so we could work across the
whole region
um an idea put forward by the future
final crew up in Montana flat near
riversdale was to convert underutilized
public spaces into food production and
while this is by no means a new idea
um it was really valuable to have
um sheer around this because he's
actually trialling Innovative methods up
in the riversdale community right now
um so food hubs are used being used
nationally and internationally to
reinvigorate local food system they
utilize economies of scale and alleviate
challenges that small scale producers
May commonly face for example around
distribution networks they work on a
principle of collaboration rather than
competition
so as you can see our community holds
the answers to rejuvenating our local
food system and it's an absolute
privilege to work with them in this bold
Endeavor so we're continuing to work on
developing
co-creation a regional strategy and
action plan for food system
interventions in Southland and we are
here to invite Gore District Council to
be an active participant in this process
and um so we would like to connect with
appropriate members of your staff
whether that's comms or Community
Lifestyles
um whatever that looks like and ensure
that
um this piece of work is also meeting
the needs of the ghoul community and
that we're truly all pulling together
working together to ensure that good
food is accessible to our whole
community
thank you for the opportunity to present
and I would love to answer any questions
that you have
so you're sorry um
getting people
at the local community
yes so Community Gardens are definitely
a piece of the puzzle and they have such
a powerful role to play in terms of
helping to share Knowledge and Skills
around food production but also just
bringing the community together you know
helping people to connect with one
another
however one thing that we know is that
Community Gardens are unlikely to
produce food on a scale that is going to
be able to feed a whole town or
community so
um so we so Community Gardens are a
vital piece of the puzzle but they're
not the whole answer so this piece of
work is about kind of like working
to to see where we need to be working
variety of different levels and in
different spaces to make to make lasting
systems change
and Nate and that sort of track
yes yes absolutely I mean it's a really
really big Wicked problem how we feed
our communities and we don't have
um easy answers or Solutions but what
we're committed to is all coming
together to nut out the solutions
ourselves as a community and to
um and to try things and you know to
experiment make some mistakes learn a
bit you know get back up and try some
more so there's no easy answer but yes
ultimately we want everyone in our
community to be able to eat beautiful
delicious nutritious food regardless of
where they live how much they earn any
other personal characteristic yeah
kids
in in the event that an area of
Southland had an event similar to what's
happening in the North Island at present
does your organization
as a place so that it can actually
contribute at times of disasters
High Collective itself is not set up to
be
an emergency
response you know organization or a food
relief organization however their
participating members who who are in
that line of work so we have active
participation from Emergency Management
Southland and connections with a variety
of organizations who would be on the
front line of that relief and we want to
support the regional coordination of
relief and ensure that our networks and
our connections across Southland are
strong so that if something like that
was to happen then we're ready that's
definitely an aspect of this um broad
piece of work that we're doing yeah
foreign
thank you food security and
sustainability is a going to be a huge
issue for New Zealand and I think it's
at the heart of our cost of living
crisis at the moment how is this working
in other areas and how can you explain
how it's working
I mean we know that you're getting
people involved but do you do you
purchase a farm and or have a farmer
volunteer or how does it work in places
like Auckland
Dunedin and we're just a small
District really so how would it work for
us
that's some very very good questions
there
um so I guess to answer that I would say
that um
there there's been an understanding that
we need
um to all come together and find a way
to
um
to collaborate and
um and to to pull together in order to
address these big picture issues
um so there's there's similar kind of
chi collectives that exist in all
different parts of New Zealand and they
each look a little bit different in the
areas and the things that they do
um obviously unique to the needs of
their Community
but the
um but the thing that everyone has in
common is that they are
um
they're they're basically looking for
community-led ground up Solutions rather
than top-down Solutions
um so that
um the the solutions will be fit for
purpose because
um sometimes well often when you get a
top-down approach it actually doesn't
work for their Community you know just
put a big one-size-fits-all rule whether
it relates to farming or lunches and
schools or whatever it is and it doesn't
necessarily work for the community that
it's going into so
um
so but there's a if you're interested I
would suggest that you look at the Mana
Kai initiative which is being championed
by the alt Theodore Circle they're
called so there is a national strategic
framework
um that there is very similar
incorporates the elements of this good
food road map
um
and they have basically said that there
needs to be action at Community level to
develop Food Systems local food systems
that work for those communities
and then there's also an organization
that set up a few years back called the
zero hunger Collective or korehkai and
their their chief executive is a member
of that aotearo Circle and they are
doing research currently into looking at
how the root causes of foods secure
insecurity and and how to address those
and I think they're you know part of
their focus is around looking at incomes
and debt levels and that kind of thing
as well so we
we're seeing this good food roadmap
strategic framework being used at a
community level in different parts of
New Zealand
um it's just kind of like a way to a
useful way to frame up the conversation
so that you can find a way forward
because it's such a big curly issue that
you can't
you can't do it all at once you've got a
kind of bite off a piece at a time does
that make sense so you just you get
people working together you try some
things you you see how you go and you
make a bit of hip way but definitely
connected into that national network and
learning from one another and there's
lots of smart heads that are being that
are looking at this issue at a national
level at the moment as well
hope that answers the question
yeah how do we encourage people to eat
health and sorry
absolutely so I think
I think that they're Healthy Families
initiative works on is about making
their their Healthy Choice the Easy
Choice so it's no point
um you know asking telling someone to
eat healthy when you after putting a big
plate of unhealthy food in front of them
you know what I mean um so it's about
how we change the environments whether
those are physical or social
environments that we're in in order to
support
um the the healthy choice to be the Easy
Choice and that's probably something
where Council can play really vital role
in looking at you know how how that ties
in with planning or you know or
different kind of Economic Development
um sort of
activity that might be happening in the
region yeah
thank you very much for that and thank
you councilors for those questions that
was very informative and I'm sure we
will be in contact Lots over the ltp
face thank you for that thank you so
much
moving on we are going to jump to
page 56 Point number 10. um so the
council and governance committee terms
of reference
did we have any further additions from
the report writer Rex
no I'll take the reporters read uh you
worship I I just will reiterate a couple
of points out of the report that might
generate some discussion or further
discussion uh and further clarification
from elected members
um
I think it's important to reiterate that
this report and the subsequent terms of
reference have been developed based on
the preliminary information that's
provided to the December meeting uh
which talked about the uh the purpose of
the Committees the membership the
frequency and the operational
responsibilities Etc the terms of
reference that are in front of you today
have exp expanded into a bit more around
the delegations and the powers to act
with respect to that so first thing is
just say that it's it's re and it's all
reinforced or referenced back to uh the
December report but also add that um by
trying to provide them in a standardized
and with some clarity around
consistent format Etc what we're trying
to show here is that these committees
while individual in nature actually work
to operate
across the whole of the governance
structure of council and to that end I
think you will have also received some
information about some further
opportunities for further briefings
throughout the year
on development of ltps and other issues
ETC related to our operation and
organization going forward so those are
probably the key points we worship in
adding to the report
and hopefully we'll provide some clarity
and Confirmation around questions with
regards to frequency and questions with
regards to the whole of council approach
that the Committees operate under I'm
having to answer any questions and
provide further information
big fit Rick's and leading into that are
there any questions from elected members
to Rex I'm at this stage just keeping
those questions to only Rex
no burning Christians
so I thank you Rick for putting the
reports together
um there seems to be a whole lot of work
that's been put into it and it flows
quite nicely
uh I think there are some some issues
that I guess I kind of wanted to table
um and start a bit of a discussion
around uh and I've got three points
written down here the first seems to be
that the recommendation in the minutes
from councilor hovel about bi-monthly
meetings largely isn't included in this
report and neither is it included later
on so I'm not sure if if the government
support has dates for what a bi-monthly
would look like but it was
a recommendation it was even a motion um
in those minutes so uh I think that's
something that we need to discuss
whether we're going to have bi-monthly
or quarterly
the second uh point that I have to make
is I'm still uneasy about having every
counselor on every committee
um and the question I think I'd put to
the table to
summarize versus what's the point and
the powers not having uh what's the
point of having committees without any
powers uh if we're all sitting around
all of those committees it seems
pointless to uh put a recommendation to
the same people at the top table
uh
uh is is most recognizing that most
councilors have full-time jobs I'd like
to offer a bit of an ultimatum
um that we have voluntary
um stepping off of at least one
committee each uh that means it's fair
for everyone and ideally
um they would voluntary step off one
that they have the least knowledge or
experience
um I do have a list written down I ran
through it a month or two ago which I'm
happy to share but I kind of want to
hear views around the table um on that
one
the alternative that I just want to make
uh all the members aware of is that if
we do decide to keep everyone on every
committee with the amount of time
constraints that I know a number of
councilors have there will be a bit of
public scrutiny and possibly meeting
media around missing consecutive
meetings and things like that so it's
it's really out of protection for those
members there's quite a few meetings
coming up
um but I'm happy to hear thoughts on
that one
uh and the third one to be discussed or
to at least bring to the attention of
elected members is more committees leads
to to more pressure on our government
support
um which is already pretty strained at
the moment um just from it being a
part-time role and Susan's doing a
fantastic job but I think we do need to
advise the the chief executive
um around kind of the support levels
that we need to be able to govern
correctly
um whether we're happy with it with the
current state or whether when we're
adding an extra four committees to our
already pre-brisic schedule whether we
need a bit more support those are just
my thoughts I will open it up to the
floor for debate and then hopefully we
can get to some motions that we can give
some direction to start does anyone want
to First crack at it
two week oh cancel the Stringer uh just
about voluntary stepping off committees
um
yes that would work in in my case there
are or there is a committee there that
probably isn't suited to my skill set
um so I would probably be in favor of
that but I'll be up to everyone else as
well
consulary thank you Mr Mayor um
I I understand just taking down the
notes very quickly you said step off a
committee if you had the least
experience well surely that's a
committee that you should be on because
you you can learn
yeah I hear your point counselor
um but ultimately there will be some
that people have more experience more
knowledge on feel like they can provide
and some where they'll be catching up to
everyone who has that experience so
whether they want to go on that Learning
Journey with a really busy schedule I'm
I'm not sure
Council Hotel
if I can throw a couple more things into
the mix thing and one one of them may
really be a question
and I'm not clear as to where the
regulatory functions of the council sit
in the committee structure and and I'm
thinking of them building control liquor
licensing
um dogs and and the rest of it
um and and while I've got some thoughts
I'd be interested in some feedback on
that the the second issue was that under
the Local Government Act the committee
structure is set up
the ACT enables committees to have
subcommittees unless the terms of
reference say otherwise and at present
the terms of reference say that the
Committees do not have powers to set up
subcommittees now there's three examples
that come to mind immediately where it
would be useful to have subcommittees
actually sitting under
um committees themselves rather than
under full Council
um there's the roading committee that
rather than Under full Council would sit
better under assets there is the
district playing subcommittee that we've
run in the past and that would sit
better under planning and policy there
is a third one in terms of grants that
would probably sit better as a
subcommittee and the community
well-being with each of those committees
then being given powers to actually act
and report back via the committee
structure Auto for Council so I just lay
those on on the table and I'm happy to
expand on those and offer more thoughts
particularly in terms of some of the
functions of council that don't appear
to be assigned to any committee
thank you for that councilor do we have
any motion creating ideas around the
table
um I think what might be the best method
to get through these is as I can propose
the motion we can debate that one
individually
um and put it to the floor and we can go
through them one by one
if that suits everyone there might be
more motions that fall out of that
so I'll start off with
um whether there'll be a mover uh well
let's let's have the conversation about
bi-monthly or quarterly that
what's what's the feeling around the
table uh I think that bi-monthly means
that we can stay on top of the the
workload
um that we're getting more information
more often uh and it really only adds
adds a couple more meetings I I don't
know
um if there's a there's a conflicting
opinion around the table there
customer fell
yeah just in regard to that to start the
debate um
what is the workload for the council
staff in regard having bi-monthly versus
quarterly uh I know that we can probably
all
even the case that we've got employment
and various other appointments but we
probably need to look at what that
constitutes with them and I'd be happy
to explore that and find out what
pressure we're putting on or creating
pressure by increasing the number of
meetings
maybe through the CEO or can answer that
to do you feel comfortable answering
debt on the spot
yeah um thanks to Worship in councilman
fell
um there's a little bit of trepidation
about bi-monthy meetings in terms of
workload but it's not so much in terms
of pumping out agendas the the risk is
that we'll get into a cycle where a lot
of operational reports will be published
produced and you'll know what's going on
but there won't be a lot of time left
for the the Deep dive into the policy
areas because you're you're still on a
treadmill of monthly Council meetings by
monthly committee meetings
um but like anything we can give it a go
and and I think in this whole structure
there was a Unwritten commitment to
perhaps review after six months of
operation
um you I think you'll find some
committees lend themselves to buy
monthly and that's why the ordinal risk
has got a lot uh you could argue I think
probably assets and infrastructure would
also lend itself but potentially policy
and planning and definitely community
evolving are more likely to be quarterly
and I don't see that there would be a
gaping pressing need to intensify the
meeting schedule and those two areas
that's my that's my gut feel mainly
because policy and planning is new and
will take a weird while to find its feet
and Community wellbeing also relatively
new but we have seen in the past that
agendas are not specifically time
dependent and we haven't had a community
well-being meeting for about five months
I think it is and we've got the agenda
prepared but it's it's not substantial
it's it's fine but it's not substantial
so my office off the cuff assessment
would be policy and planning quarterly
along with well-being and if anything
assets infrastructure and water and risk
by monthly
foreign
's uh question a slightly different way
as well I suppose um
my introduction I talked about this
being an ecosystem of a community of a
governance committee or governance
structure
and so so you and Mr Perry talked about
monthly Council meetings and then if it
was bi-monthly
um committee meetings of four of those
um you know that's quite a significant
workload uh just in itself on top of
that the senior management team over the
last two weeks Steve that has developed
a a work-backed in developing an annual
work program for the organization
based around our legislative
requirements of delivering on a
long-term plan an annual plan and an
annual report
uh as well as the reform agenda as well
as the district plan work as well as a
number of other
external factors which will which are
impacting on the operation and
organization of the and workloads so
it's not just I suppose what I'm trying
to say here councilman fellas the
workload questions not just about
servicing a committee structure IT
services all the other stuff that needs
to be conducted and developed at that
strategic level which involves and will
need to involve Council law input as
well
um so I would just ask that that be
factored into when you're considering
bi-monthly committee committee
frequencies versus all of the other
add-ons that will go into the mix
throughout this calendar year especially
um as it's not it's it's not going to be
just servicing the Committees
thank you for that Rex do we have any
other opinions I I feel like as this
conversation has developed and around
the ltp talks and how quickly they're
coming with us the amount of Reform
um just in reflection uh maybe coarsely
is the best with a review at the end of
the year
and that review can be wider to see if
those committees are fit for purpose and
frequency is fit for purpose
did the chairs have any opinions as
specifically the ones we'll be meeting
quarterly or are they relatively neutral
on this
counts over in in terms of policy and
planning
um I I hear what the chief executive
saying and I'm the same male May well
apply to community and well-being he did
highlight that the fourth committee May
in fact need to meet bi-monthly so maybe
we do look at a split but referring back
to planning and policy the major
workload is going to be the district
plan
and and the planning and policy
committee is presently set up I believe
has a role in terms of uh almost a a
governance role in terms of the process
of the district plan with a subcommittee
actually working on the district plan
with delegations under that committee so
if the district playing committee or
subcommittee sorry
had delegations that would remove the
need for bi-monthly meetings of of the
planning and policy committee
issues relating to the actual hearing of
submissions and that process as a matter
that needs to be looked at in more
detail there is another aspect and will
come up when we talk in the terms of
references that we don't actually have
in place that present any delegations
under our planning and and other
processes where if an objection is
received or we have a notified
application
um of having a system set up to quickly
deal with hearings under that so I see a
need to actually set up as well a
hearing panel made up of counselors who
have the suitable qualifications so
they're in a position to respond quickly
rather than slowly
misdeme
could I ask a question of the chief
executive is that not what we did in
previous terms that we had committee set
up as the need arose for each specific
submission
that's where you Worship in the past off
the top of my head uh the council tended
to be the instrument of Delegation so
the council would say we'll set up a
subcommittee dealing with this aspect
and the subcommittee uh tended to report
back to uh the council what counts for
hoval is suggesting is the the standing
committees have the power to create a
subcommittee and there's a lot of mirror
in that the only caveat old ad is that
if you have a committee which is not to
cancel the whole which person I think is
the far better way to go they have a
small committee you do run the risk of
committees spawning subcommittees
without the parent body really actually
knowing what's going on that so
sometimes the smarter way can be to
create the create the subcommittee need
at the council but get the subcommittee
report back to the standing committee
and get on this work so that everyone
knows just how many subcommins we've got
out there because
and that's that's very much that advice
is predicated on the basis that if you
have committees less than the whole
then it makes make sure the council is
connected and at least knows what's
going on otherwise you'll grow legs and
arms that you didn't know existed
sorry I'm just gonna and I'll let you
speak to the Keith I'm just going to
direct it back to the bi-monthly or
quarterly meetings and I just wanted to
get your councilor um Dixon's choice
just because with the community
well-being committee being quite top
heavy in the past
thank you wish if I'm more than happy to
go um quarterly with those meetings I
don't think the agendas are particularly
full but I'm just wondering if everyone
if all the councils are not going to be
there do we have to change the Quorum
for some of these because
we've got six I think it's a quorum for
every meeting
do we need to look at that as well
okay
yeah absolutely so just just to move on
I'm getting there's not a particularly a
whole lot of support across the table
for bi-monthly so we will drop that and
keep it at quarterly unless there are
any objections no that's cool
uh moving on we will go through
um so a motion to have councilors um
voluntarily or removed off the following
committees uh
to your point uh councilor Dixon
yes I believe the Quorum would still be
set at about half
um so say if two voluntarily voluntarily
stepped off a committee dropped to 10
the corner B5
um
debate I've seen this support from from
Joe not school words in your mouth
counselor read but not so much in
support of taking it off
uh councilors coming off committees or
were you just asking the question
earlier sorry I was just asking the
question but I would assume that if any
counselor wished to attend any of those
meetings they're still able to do that
100 yes yeah uh the only difference
would be voting rights within that
committee however all the
recommendations come back to council
anyway so they would eventually get
invoked
are we all happy to it seems like
there's a bit of agreement to to step
off some committees do we want to go
through my list of kind of what I had
proposed and if there's any objections
Council right
um I would suggest Mr Mia that maybe
that's something that individual
counselors could choose to do
yeah I would I would tend to agree I'm
just cautious of trying to getting this
locked up and finalized freely
um and not delaying it for for another
council meeting to to then approve it
um I guess through the chief executive
to
can we leave the the membership open
um and do that process away from the or
does it need to be at the table
through
your worship yet does need to be at a
table the membership does
need to be confirmed otherwise we're
calling him a committee meeting of
members who are not known and the
committee meetings are just around the
corner
I do Wonder to help the meeting whether
you if there is a A
Renewed realization that perhaps you'd
like a Committees of list in the whole
whether rather than asking someone to
step off
is whether you are prepared to land on
an optimal number of membership of a
committee
and then
assign the names that way so otherwise
you might have some that don't volunteer
and and you're left with a a rather
strange collection of numerical
sequences so I wonder whether you
worship whether you could if if every
member of the council opted out of a
committee maybe you could look at a
committee structure of say eight members
just to throw it out there
and
that would be eight members a piece
still a very good representation and I'm
sure that members made their wishes and
interests known as worship and the
um meetings that followed the election
so but that's a suggestion for worship
just trying to speed things up because
the committee agendas are being
assembled as we speak but we need to
know who to send their gender to
so the the original idea was to make the
Committees a size of 10 with with one
person stepping off each committee so
you're still part of three um and then
and then walking one
I've just found that while I
put a number next to all of your names I
don't actually have the list in front of
me which is really helpful
um
did we feel comfortable saying what what
we would want to be taking off councilor
heister
yeah I think the suggestion from the
chief executive has Merit especially
that the new commodity structured
um contains the pair to recommend rather
than the pair to act I personally am
more comfortable with a
shorter lineup for committees and yeah
maybe eight is an appropriate number
rather than names
just just to continue though I'm Keen to
explore what councilor Val has in mind
in terms of policy and planning and he
talks about powers of the committee to
delegate to a subcommittee I wonder what
those pairs may be
happy to respond and and it really comes
at two levels and and one is that none
of the regulatory functions of council
other than planning have been provided
for in the committee structure and in
terms of the terms of reference and I'm
wondering whether they should sit with
what is presently turned planning and
policy
um so that would be the the alcohol
liquor licensing the dogs and the rest
of it
and really a key component of those
activities is really reporting an
opportunity to report to council and an
opportunity of counselors to actually
question some of the information that
presently appears in bulletins and it's
not just the bulletins for one committee
but right across Council it's good to
prepare the bulletins and put them out
there for the public but we as
counselors should have the opportunity
of actually going down to a few other
layers
um in in terms of the
um planning and policy Committee in the
way that it's set up a present there was
also some duplication across the terms
of reference with reference to climate
change and economic development
planning and policy looks at the
Strategic issues happening in the
district and I think that Economic
Development sits nicely within that
framework of that committee as well
rather than being under Community
well-being which is more people oriented
rather than growth oriented the other
one relates to climate change and while
all of the Committees have a
responsibility to think of climate
change in terms of assets and the impact
of flooding on assets and risk
management
and and also in terms of community
well-being there's a climate change
aspect I see the policy side of of
climate change actually sitting with
planning and policy as well so I see
that as really the role of that
committee being a bit wider than what
set out in the documentation in terms of
delegations
um I would see in the midterm a hearing
committee being established that had
delegations to make decisions
um on submissions Lodge to the district
plane I would envisage it as extremely
efficient both in times and money to
have a hearing panel established that
had delegations make decisions on
objections to processes of planning
consents so if someone actually received
a request for further information on a
consent they have the ability to object
to that in the present we don't have any
delegation set up that enable those to
be resolved other than with the chief
executive from what I can see
and would also avoid the need of
bringing in the outside Commissioners at
the cost involved there to hear notified
applications so I don't see the the
committee legally cannot have a
delegation to approve a district plan
that's required to go back
Council Dixon can I just say that um
councilor hovel can attend any meetings
he doesn't actually have to have voting
rights but he can attend all of them if
he wishes
that's that's a fair point
okay are we are we comfortable
um delegating to the the number eight
feature the Committees
uh can I have a move of that motion
uh Council stranger councilor Reed and I
will put the motion all those in favor
please say aye
and against the motion is carried moving
on to whether subcommittees have the
power sorry whether the Committees have
powers to create subcommittees can I
please have a mover for that motion
to to assist
um I think the chief executive's
explanation of to keep control and know
what is going on on comfortable not to
have uh the Committees with the power to
establish subcommittees but the council
establishes the subcommittees and they
then fall under the auspices of a
council committee
thank you for that okay all right we'll
cross that one out as well
and uh given the the extra pressure with
having an extra
um
committee on the cards
um I would like to move a motion that we
have a review done into the governance
support function uh to be presented at
the next council meeting to see whether
that support is accurate do I have a
second of that motion
councilor Stringer and open for debate
councilor hi Sid the only question I'd
raise is we have operated with this
number of committees and past councils
and cope with it so I'm just curious as
to what the additional workload May
entail I guess that's why you're asking
for a report so I comment maybe circular
let's make the point
uh thank you for that Council I said I I
guess that the difference would be and
correct me if I'm wrong but there's been
a full-time governance support person in
the past whereas it's now part-time role
so it's more reporting on the
differences there and whether we need a
full-time role or not was was the key
aspect do we have any further debate on
that one
I will put the motion all those in favor
please say aye
and against the motion is carried
moving on
so now flipping to number 14 which is
the Bridge Project well actually Bridge
end water pipe
did we have any further additions from
the report writer mat
uh thank you worship
um you know take the report as read
um I guess I'll just add
um
and there's
um most of the councilors aware with the
helps of the with the help of the
communications team
um we did a
a little bit of community engagement
um at The Amp show
around this project
and it um it was a pretty useful day I
found
we had close to over 200 people come
through the the council's site
um and in terms of of this project we
we took a bit of a poll
um in terms of
um what the community thought we should
do whether we should
continue to investigate a bridge
or just focus on getting the pipelines
across the river
and so at the end of the day we had 60
votes in terms of continuing to to look
at the bridge versus 35 votes
um to just focus on the on the pipes
across the river
and we also for those people who were
still in support of investigating a
bridge we also got them to
um
put a mark on a map where they thought
the bridge
would the best location for the bridge
and
um
there were an entitled um 14 people
thought that the Church Street Surrey
Street location was the best
um
4H for either Rock Street or somewhere
near Walnut Grove and another
five votes for the Lawrence Street
location
um
so yeah as I said it was a really useful
day to get a bit of an idea of what the
community was thinking around this
project
and yeah there's obviously quite a
split opinion
um some some people are quite certain
that we should just focus on the
pipelines but there's obviously also a
large portion of the community who are
still very keen to see a bridge
um yeah I'm happy to take any questions
on the report
thanks for that Matt
um I will open it to questions I guess
my first one to be a bit cheeky is uh
with that straw poll at The Amp show did
you see any children uh voting in that
uh
through the chair yes we did
um have a few children voting
um
where they tried to put in more more
than one vote we tried to censor it out
and and remove those extra votes
thanks for that Matt uh anyone asked
around the table questions for Matt and
just met at this stage we can't support
it
um my question thank you
restriction matters um do we have we
secured the funding from Waka okay with
for the bridge
through your worship no we haven't and
that's not something we can do until we
have a bit more certainty around the
Bridge location and things
um so yeah it'll be something that we
still need to work through
um but yeah we need to do some
investigation work and come up with an
alternative design in in a location and
things before we can get that confirmed
thank you uh Council McKinsey
if
if there is a change of government
would that money still be available
could that change
are we relying on it too much
worship
um I might give a pastor chief executive
here but I guess from my point of view I
think there's no guarantees of the
funding at this stage
um and um yeah it's as I said it's
something that we need to continue to
work through
and and come up with an alternative
design and location and
get to a stage where we can get that
funding guaranteed
I'm sure you worship two key points to
note yeah
has not said that there's no longer
funding available there's a possibility
uh how strong we're still trying to find
out in terms of a change of government
it's important to emphasize that Waka
katahi is not actually a government
Department it's a crown agency with its
own board which makes its own funding
decisions
so it's a little bit more independent
than a normal government Department
therefore I don't think it is as prone
to
funding changes through a change of
government as other government
departments would be
I wonder whether it's our decision to
make
in any case in terms of three Waters
legislation
is it our decision or something that an
organization is going to come along
later and make a decision in terms of
how to get a pipe across the river
councilor Hove out two things one could
you please wait because I was going to
give it to these guys over here and
secondly just questions format at this
stage um before we get into into debate
so that was a question format yep
through your worship yes so that is
another factor that we have to consider
is we're now because of the
um the fact that we're getting close to
the proposed reform we would have to
before awarding
um a contract would have to talk it
through with the DIA
and get
yeah
and particularly with the bridge option
um
I don't believe we'd be in a position
it's probably unlikely that would be in
a position to start construction before
uh the reform started
um and so then we would be handing that
over to the new entities to deliver
if we were to go down the the pipe our
only option there's probably a
reasonable possibility that we would
be in a position to have a contract
awarded in construction started before
the reform happened
um
and again we would have to get Dia
approval before awarding that contract
um but I can't see them
having a problem with installing just a
pipeline giving us
um 100 focused on water services rather
than dual purpose
cancer Stringer
three worship to me
um
if
if the three Waters take her over on it
and we don't have it sorted by then
whilst the likelihood of them delaying
the project and all the stuff that I've
got to do like are we going to get oh
this could be five years down the track
six years down the track
what's that
uh through your worship
um
I mean at this stage the entities of
um there's been I guess an assurance
provided that the entities will deliver
on all the council's ltp projects and
this is one of our council's most
significant three Waters ltp project so
I'd expect them to carry it on and
deliver it relatively
uh early on
um and and I guess what we can control
between now and then is getting as much
work done and getting things progressed
as far as possible so that um so that
you know we make sure that everything is
lined up so that can be done as soon as
possible
uh councilman Phil
not through your worship uh mate just
the community consultation part is a
real worry for me
um that's one of the next steps we've
got to go to but we haven't really had
engagement with the public really on the
next ideas here yet because that is
critical the talk around town and the
district is massive and um what we did
at the show was great but that's not a
big and a pole to know what we're doing
and we're with where the feeling is out
there
do you have any comment on that Matt or
so you worship um yeah so completely
agree that what we did at The Amp
showground was was just I guess a sample
and just a taster I guess if you like
and certainly
um agree that there's there's a need to
go out to the wider community
make sure that everyone has a chance to
provide input
oh yeah counselor Reed
thank you Mr me um Matt thanks for the
report obviously a lot of work
um one question I did have was about the
pipeline and the question is does that
3.6 to 4.1 million include the Geotech
costs
through your worship yes it would
um I guess on on the costs um
uh
it is important to note that that those
costs that have been provided are only
relative costs so it's purely to provide
a a comparison between the options um
given the the high level assessment
um a lot more work needs to be done in
terms of investigation and the design to
confirm that those cost estimates are
accurate
thank you
uh Council hosted
he thinks through you Mr Miriam to Matt
just the assessment tool
um assumes that the uh Cote funding is
in place on some projects was there any
testing done to remove that and just in
terms of priority that it significantly
changed the score of the Waka kotay
funny was removed from any of those
Bridge projects for Apple's records
through your worship uh no we didn't do
any testing to remove that that funding
um I guess it's an assumption that yeah
that we're working on that um
that we would be able to get that
funding
um
you know obviously it would would make a
reasonable
change and potentially the the pot only
options would become a lot more
favorable if you remove that funding
councilor Dixon
I'm just wondering um you worship to met
is there a deadline of when we should
have all of the towns water up to the
safety standards because I mean if we go
down the road of a bridge in a walkway
again this is going to take some time to
put through I would imagine and then
we're going through that consenting
process again and Community
some community members are not happy
with us looking at this bridge bridge
option again so
um is there a time frame around
how long we have
through your worship but I don't believe
there's a
a deadline provided at this stage
um I guess
the the short answer would be we need to
get it done as soon as possible
um obviously at parts of
um cause water supply don't currently
meet the drinking water standards
we need to meet those standards as soon
as possible
not that I'm aware of no
any further questions from that
no
right since it's been a Hot Topic um
it's been over three years in the
process and close to a million dollars
spent to get back to where I quite
frankly believe is Square One um with a
bit of a report
um I think it's worth us going around
the table one by one and sharing our
views um I think it's going to be very
critical for the community to hear what
we have to say
um and I don't want anyone to to you
know be the silent majority on this one
so I'll go with my quick three points
I'm on try and talk slow so you can make
comments
um and let's let's try and have a robust
debate and get somewhere with this so
the the first point is around the report
um and raising my concerns with the
reports and I do want to thank Matt and
Becca for the hard work that they've put
in
so when the draft report was workshopped
the number one option was actually the
the underground boar at the time I
raised the point that it's interesting
that the bridge doesn't have more of a
social impact um to make it number one
uh the cultural aspects were then
reassessed which is more than fair uh
and now the the bridge ranks the highest
so the reason I mentioned this is
because on paper the decision was really
50 50. it was a very small change that
flipped the underground bore option to
go from the first option down to the
second one
what I feel is also really missed in
this report is the political impacts
revisiting the the bridge
um and also the financial
impacts I wouldn't hesitate for a second
um that we would face legal action again
um around going for a bridge option
um and not to admit not to mention the
amount of scrutiny the council would
receive for visiting an option uh that
has already ultimately failed
the second point I want to make is
around funding uh this report has as has
been stated um indicates that what
kotahi will kick in 2.4 million dollars
to this project we have a meeting
managers that could have a meeting later
in the week to see where that funding is
still available
um but like Matt has already alluded to
there's a whole lot of unknowns around
that funding so if that funding isn't
there
that makes the bridge 2.4 million
dollars more expensive than the
underground for and even if we get that
funding it's the bridge is still more
expensive
the third one is around consultation
which has already been slightly
discussed here
um and this is no detriment to the staff
in any way shape or form
um but I'm I'm underwhelmed um and I
understand that it's what's included
here is uh regular practices to engage
with the community but I I think it it
hasn't particularly worked so far and it
doesn't fill me with confidence
um once again that's not an attack on
the staff I think it's something that we
need to take control of as councilors
uh what I'm seriously the most
um there's no nothing mentioned here
around kind of door knocking for those
effective um directly by the bridge
um and will have their views impacted
um and targeting stakeholders is quite
vague and I think we need to be set up a
bit
what unsetters me the most about this is
that the materials won't be finished
till late March which is understandable
for me materials these types
consultation will be done in April May
so realistically we'll come back to the
same point that we're here now
um in June of this year
over the last few days when this Council
agenda went up I've had an outpour a
protest for the bridge
um I up to that point I did share the
views of Matt that it has been
relatively 50 50.
um and it's no secret where I lie on
this issue with my back to basics
campaign I I firmly sit in the camp of
the underground boar however it's not up
to me it's up to the 12 individuals
around this table
and I think it's up to us that we need
to stand up and face our community and
hear what they have to say and make a
decision
I'm not going to fall into the old ways
of the previous Council of delaying hard
decisions
I want to make a decision on this and
and move on
so I propose that we hold a public
meeting between now and the next council
meeting
um we're still staff to help us answer
questions but ultimately governance
should bear the brunt of this
and actually listen to our community
have them talk to us
around these three options which has
been proposed in option four have that
conversation with them come back in
March and actually get on with the job
so those are my three points I'm going
to give everyone a fair shot at their
their opinions on this project I think
it's important for the community to hear
your your viewpoints does anyone want to
get us started we'll do one at a time um
so you'll get your turn and then and
then someone else and we can Circle back
at the end councilor McKenzie
through your worship I have a
a question to ask as well as a motion
I'd like to pop so but I'll give you my
comments first because that's what we're
doing at the moment
is Britain and others are probably aware
there's been scuttleback going around
the town of supposed materials already
have been having been purchased for Sid
Bridge some time ago for a start I'd
like to get that out of the way does
anybody in this room know of any
materials that have been purchased for a
bridge and hidden in a shed somewhere
so I take that as a no it's I thank you
because of a couple of people have come
to me and said the same story so I think
it's best we put it out in the year and
we talk about it I'm doing that right
now so no knowledge of that thank you
now sorry to interrupt Council McKenzie
can we also have that medicine
um that there was an acknowledgment from
all councilors and also staff
um that there are no materials hidden in
a shed somewhere thank you thank you now
that I do have emotion I would like to
put but you don't want me to do that at
the moment do you
you can make your your views here I'll
mention my American my motion
um
look I've been typed out my motion is
if testing and total costs meet this
council's satisfaction we should proceed
with the under River option at Macon
Street
this would include calling for tenders
to be considered by Council so basically
you get my opinion what I think about
I think I'm in agreeance with you get on
with it get it done move on
thank you councilor that's my oh one
more thing I will add is if it's under
the blood oh sorry I said bloody if it's
under the river we don't have to worry
about flood damage
thank you councilor that's my opinion
thank you next up do we have a volunteer
councilor Reed
thank you Mr
to me I think um
personally we still Community
consultation is what we need the fact
that you've got some people who feel
quite strongly one way the other is
probably only the tip of the iceberg and
I suggest we cannot go any further at
all in this discussion really to me is
quite irrelevant until we have the idea
of what the community wants and until we
actually go out explain to them they are
three options and they have their view
that's just my that's my view
thank you for your counselor councilor
mcphail
thank you your worship I wasn't
quite prepared to have a party political
broadcast statement appeared in front of
me in regard to in regard to what I was
going to discuss in regard to the bridge
outcome
um
I'm a firm believer that the
consultation yes it was lacking yes
there wasn't doors knocked on yes if you
look at where we're sitting at the
moment
I feel like we're in a Time Walk
we've gone around and we've come back to
the start again I think probably the
priority is not to State what your
um
what your main
preference would be but actually go back
to community and ask them I don't think
we need to go down and get caned again I
think we need to um actually line up and
whether it's a public meeting or
whatever mediums used that's probably
the most important thing
um that's all I say about that put it
back to them but I think we do need to
get some expediency into it we are in a
standstill with um whatever uh what our
staff are looking at and how we've got
this quality water on the other side of
the river it needs to come into the main
system we need to work out how to do
that
um and as for the three Waters that's
discussed earlier uh I think a little
beer will be and if we've got it there
in the ltp we'd go with it
that's the end of my broadcast
thank you for that counselor um very
well off the cuff presentation there uh
next up
councilor heisted
yeah I like I think the report makes it
quite clear that the assessment tool is
only a guide and it's highly highly
debatable but the other thing the report
I think is correct in is is recommending
that option four is engagement with the
community on the options not on my
location on what are we doing are we
going under the water are we going above
it and does it contain a
an amenity value in terms of pedestrians
or bikes so to me that is the
appropriate way to go forward and I
think we should rely on the staff to to
guide us on the most efficient way to
gather that opinion from the community a
public meeting may be part of it but I
don't think it's all of it if we want to
do this efficiently and correctly we
should refer to the staff I don't know
if Sonia's got any comments she'd like
to give us that
uh thank you and through the worship
through your worship yes I agree um
public meetings are one way of gathering
information but we've got to realize not
all rape payers live or can get to a
public meeting there's lots of other
channels that we already have well
established where we can access large
groups of people such as our digital
channels where we've got you know over
1200 subscribers that we can directly
connect with
I think for that Council and thank you
for that Sonia Keith oval you're up next
firstly
um I think met for the report I believe
it's a good report
the assessment tool that is in there is
a tool that has been supported by the
courts and
um well you can argue about the detail
of the way that it's been done it is a
robust approach in in terms of
identifying and putting forward things
forward debate
I wonder as a question whether
consultation we've got the app available
to us with all the numbers on it we've
got a council satisfaction survey
planned at some time and whether they
may not be an opportunity to do
something
um as part of that
as another General comment the previous
consent process was flawed it had a pro
a procedural error in it that the court
focused on it had a design in it that
was totally inappropriate for the
location
and I I think it doesn't rule out
consideration of other options for a
bridge however
when you look around other councils and
the progress that they're making on
their annual plans talking about 10 rate
increases
if we are to provide the same level of
service we are providing now I suspect
and we've had no information provided to
us but I suspect we would be in the same
sort of boat
I do not believe that we as counselors
can reasonably
head in a direction of spending
unnecessary money on an option that is
not necessary to provide the prime
purpose of getting River of getting
water across the river
what that points out to me is that any
option that is just there primarily for
recreational use that is not getting
funding from New Zealand transport
Authority is not one that I would
support
similarly if funding is not available to
pay a significant contribution to it
then the option of putting a bridge
across I believe is dead in the water so
we need to have a certain a degree of
certainty in terms of the ability to
provide that funding
um and that's all I want to say in the
matter
thank you councilor councilor Dixon
um
turn two is about Community consultation
and engagement because I think the
community need to understand the cost as
well and whether we've got what funding
or not got the funding because they're
that's huge and my point of view that's
2.4 million that we don't have to go
towards a bridge so even though a
walkway in a cycleway is a nice to have
my view is that in my opinion would be a
trench
um either in the river or under the
river
because
um I think otherwise it could end up
being a very costly process
thank you councilor uh councilor
Stringer
oh look I wasn't here
um three years ago when all this process
started so I don't know
what the initial proposal was with a
included a bridge at that stage as well
whether it was just for for getting
water across the river
um more discussions with a few people in
the public uh
um they're actually sitting on the fence
that can go either way
um
my
light Bim Back to Basics it was just to
get the water across the river and get
the service to the people at the end of
the day
um
depending on how the discussion goes
with getting that funding
um
Dean if we went with the bridge option
how much of that funding is then going
to be chewed up if someone challenges Us
in court
thank you
four councilors left uh it was first a
casa got on
yeah I was here with the initial
discussions on the bridge and I've
always thought that the shortest route
is the most efficient route
where there is a bridge or under the
water
um
I'm not too worried but we've left it
too late
um
and if we go through the consenting
process I think we'll still get
objections and it'll draw it out and we
won't have any control over the end end
product
um probably looking back or even looking
now it is actually probably cheaper to
establish another treatment plant on the
west side of the river
um because if you look at what we've
spent in material we're probably
spending two and a half or three million
dollars to upgrade the treatment plant
you could actually do the same on the at
the hillbury Ave
I know it's a bit out there out of the
square but
um
the cost of piping the cost of
reticulation has skyrocketed since we
first started the project as Ramesh
originally planned to have one pro one
processing plant
but the under the under bore River will
have its risks and um we will not know
the cost until it's done
I think that councilor uh councilman
fare
thank you um
I'm not going to say what my personal
view is because until I hear what the
community say
because that's not my I've got to listen
to the community we live here and that's
what we're here for we voted by the them
here so I want to hear what they say
first there's risk in all them
um and I think to Council of Guardian
has given us an option that wasn't even
on the list so but there's yeah there is
there's risk everywhere so Community
consultation hear what the public want
and a public meeting is not the only
answer because people can over
just speak over everybody else and take
over the meeting and you don't get the
true true uh people's views
we're gonna have to go through all the
all the different
um areas of Engagement so I that's where
I stand anyway
thank you
thank you councilor two councilors left
who would like to go first
councilor Phillips
yeah thank you
I think everyone around the table knows
what My Views are and we were building I
was there three years ago
and what we wanted was the bridge across
build it for the future
uh have existing space for future parts
from your school or to the main Town
whatever it might have been
we missed the boat
um and I've got to be in Grants with
John on on this one in the aspect is
that it could be cheaper for us now to
look at
um
having a separate
water treatment plant that help we have
we haven't spent the money on the
reservoir yet it's up for upgrade we
haven't pulled down the tower we haven't
done anything over there yet the
pipeline going up to it is uh
several years old and it definitely
needs replacement the cost of the
pipeline going from the bridge up to the
water treatment plane plant alone may be
sufficient enough to Warrant thinking
about
having a separate plant over it is at
Hillary Ave once again
so those options probably may need to
think about going back to the staff and
giving us some ideas cost wise
um
but
um personally personally if we're having
to have under the river or over it I'll
personally go over it because we're
going to be building something for the
future
not just for the now
because we could spend
we don't know it's an approximate cost
and we could spend all this money
putting two pipes under the river with
an expansion of the Town either side we
want to put more water in we're going to
be once again
in the future with the cost of putting
more pipes under the river where if we
only do it once it's there for 30 40
years this bridge
I'm not going to around that long but
the councilors around the table might be
more than happy that we're prudent
enough to build it
30 years by private so
that's my views
my my view has always been the direct
route which is in this case at Bridget
Maitland Street and if it can have
something on it for cycleways or bits
and pieces fine or go under the river so
it's it's a very simple solution it you
don't want to be dragging pipes all the
way down to Rock Street and all the way
back up it's just extra stuff you've got
to service in years to come so
thank you
thank you for that councilors
um I I think that was insightful and I
think your your community now sees
everyone's viewpoints um what I'm what
I'm picking up across the table
um is that that Community consultation
is the key here
and I guess I would like to think of an
approach
um I'm like I said in my little Spiel
um I'm I'm uncomfortable with the
current plan namely the dates
um with kind of a report coming back in
May or June and ultimately given the
fact that even across the table with
this seems like a 50 50. I would hate to
go out there for a consultation spend
half of the Year doing that then we come
back to the table and we're still left
with 50 50 and then we feel like we have
to get more consultation so being weary
of of that
um
I I guess and if Sonia feels comfortable
and I don't mean to put you on the spot
are there any other options that come to
mind to kind of expedite the the process
I don't want to put your team under more
pressure
um but in terms of I don't know
consultation takes a long time but yeah
not to put you on the spot but if you
had any ideas
I'm a team of one so there you go
um look I think there's other people in
this room that are involved in community
engagement as long as I have and you do
the work at the front end you get all
the information together you get the
facts for the people so they can make an
informed decision and you have genuine
Community engagement slash consultation
you'll find that you'll have less work
at the other end so while it might seem
protracted I think if we do our work up
front
um you'll you'll have an informed
community and a community that believes
that they are part of the process so
um unfortunately I'm not sure we can we
can look at the timeline and we'll do
our best but I'm just not sure how we
can shorten it and still have genuine
consultation with the wider sector that
we need to
councilor Reed
I'd have to agree with our
Communications officer um do it once you
do it right and I really don't think we
need to be
um pressurizing ourselves time-wise at
this stage you know within reason I know
that the team will get a doubt the team
have won and we just we need to present
to people with good facts data and let
them make their choice
I'm sorry counselor but I'm going to
have to argue the contrary of I feel
like we've done it once and we've done
it wrong um otherwise we wouldn't be in
this position
um and I would hate to avoid that
um
I'm cautious of letting the public
Gallery speak on this issue
unfortunately
um
I'm sorry but um we've got to make her
make a decision as governance and come
to the community
yes absolutely will be heard
um
do we do we have any thought public
meeting is ultimately where I think we
can start and I think we'll get a pretty
good showing there of where we need to
move to next
um whether where the communities need
more information
um and I feel like we'll get a pretty
strong voice from that just based on the
the voice that I've heard over the last
couple of days
um
I'm open to other options but ultimately
I want to keep moving this forward
councilor McKinsey
sorry for interrupting you there being
but I do have a motion that I want to
put to this meeting I'll read it out
again
if T this is the motion if testing and
total costs
meet this council's satisfaction
we should proceed with the under River
option at Maitland Street this would
include calling for tenders to be
considered by Council that is my motion
to have a second look for that motion
unfortunately councilor that the motion
is not be second and councilor Stringer
did you were you wanting to Second it or
am I going to come no I was just wanting
to make a question around that to your
motion is that
taking it to or getting a set of prices
for it is that for us to buy at home and
we're still having another option of a
brooch or we what's
right
I think there's hesitancy around the
table to make that decision without the
the community
interaction first
I I'm in agreement if I want to want to
put a motion like that or something
similar whether it is for the bridge or
for the the under the river option
um as soon as possible but ultimately we
do have to go to our community and ask
um what that looks like I don't know
um and I think this is ultimately where
we're in the standstill I don't want to
have this discussion in June I don't
want to have the discussion even in May
um either this meeting or the next
meeting I would really prefer so we can
get this out of the way and we can get
it done
um and I'm also being cautious of the
team of one and putting Sonia under an
immense amount of pressure to get out
material in such a short space of time
so I'm looking for my governance to
govern and come up with clever ideas
that we can integrate with our
communities to understand their views
the council McKenzie
okay I understand it no you wanted to
Second it but can that be on the record
as a motion that I've put and can we
discuss it again in the future
it's it's there yeah thank you Council
Dixon thank you worship well we will be
putting another option there of building
a treatment plant on this side of the
river
for the public to decide upon
or is that
yeah through your worship I'm Keen to
add some comments to that suggestion
um
as I think it was Council Garden pointed
out the cost of pipelines and things
have gone up recently
um but the cost of treatment plants I
mean construction treatment plants have
also gone up
um and I'd suggest that um the
proportion increase is about the same
um but
um the the capital cost was not the only
reason that the decision was made to
centralize the treatment plant and move
away from Hilby hillbry the hillbury
site is is very constrained and so
there's issues with chemical storage and
such close vicinity to residential
property
um there's also space contract
constraints around getting chemical
deliveries into that site for
large trucks
um there's also higher operational costs
when you're operating two treatment
plants versus one
and then there's also increased costs of
future upgrades are required when you're
having to upgrade to treatment plants
versus one
um and finally
it provides having
the the single treatment plant and and
the pipes across the river provides us
more resilience in terms of how and
flexibility and in terms of how we use
our water sources
um so if one water source is low we can
rely more on the other one and vice
versa
um so there are a whole lot of different
reasons as to why we went for for the
centralization approach
Council husted
yeah look I'm I'm
I speak desire if you worship that you
want to get on with us but I think
there's a key factor that's missed in
the process is you know once we've
engaged with Community there's a role
now for staff to report to this table
and and give us detail of what the
community's asked for in terms of
costing and how we can deliver that and
is that in fact possible so for this
Council to move from consultation to
decision making I don't believe we will
be there
um and the time desired we need
professional input from the staff with
costings and risk assessment especially
around the drilling option
oh I'm sorry councilor but is this not
what's included in the report costings
and the feasibility no the the it's made
quite clear these are what did you
describe them there not rough order of
cost but for guidance only we haven't
got costings on any of these projects
these are ball packs so they from
experience these will be well off in
terms of final costings
I think bringing you back to our last
meeting and currently if I'm wrong Matt
but that was the whole point of doing
this is so they could do get direction
of looking into one option rather than
exploring in-depth both options um
because it takes a lot of resources to
explore both options but I hear you in
terms of we we can't go from
consultation directly into making a
final decision but we do need to give
direction sooner rather than later to
the likes of Matt so that he can
actually explore options in depth
um to get us those numbers
it's very critical that we go there to
the public with the correct option
costings
because
look at the look at the talk about the
library for instance right in the
misconception about the library
um and the costing on the library and
the seven million that it's cost all
right
but when you start when you explain to
people the actual true cost of the
library in the facility that's sitting
there
let's go oh I didn't realize that and
the same thing's going to happen if you
go about
going to the public without the true
costing about what you want to put there
then you're going to get yourself into
trouble and I'm don't like to be in
trouble because I like to explain to
them to the right pair who are my bosses
that were doing it correctly
thank you for that counselor Matt could
you please just um further explain if we
were to divide to dive into both options
um into that heavy detail in terms of
resources and costing
um to do such a process
through worship
um
yeah it's I guess the only way you could
have
a higher level of certainty would be to
go right through the consenting and
design process
um and and go out to Tinder for both
projects because ultimately you don't
know what the the construction cost is
going to be until you've gone out to
Tinder and and to do that for the bridge
um you probably need to go through and
get a resource consent in full design so
you would be looking at significant
expense
so sorry just to clarify without going
to consent Entertainer this is most
likely that as accurate as you're going
to get as detailed as you're going to
get as as it stands who you worship no
no
as we do the further investigation and
design work the the cost
the accuracy of the cost will become
more accurate
um
but we won't know the final cost until
the work is completed
um
the costs that are included in the
report uh what we've called a relative
cost so it allows a comparison
um this option we would expect to cost
20 more than this option
that's what we were trying to do rather
than yeah so it is very difficult
um particularly when you're looking at
13 or 14 options to to try and
um get an accurate cost estimate without
going into to very detailed and doing a
huge amount of work
but at a rough estimate
um and what the trend would show is that
when you go down both these routes
they're going to be more or less the
same costing give or take
um ballpark for for some of the bridge
options some some of them are
significantly more
cancer
we we will always have this problem of
trying to cost it but Matt's already a
relative costing across all factors is
the only way we're going to go and at
the end of the day it's going to cost
more probably and there's no doubt about
that and the Broadcasting
I don't think you'll ever get a true
tender price until you're finished
and we're at a bridge you'll probably
have a more closer tender price
at the time of tendering
but I think we're just we're exhausted
all avenues we need to talk to the
public
you wish it helps for me it seems to be
that you've got these high level
estimates they all have the same
reasonable amount of uncertainty
but what you want is a philosophical
engagement with the community about do
we aspire to have a bridge over the
river carrying a water pipe in a
um a site for your walk Community or is
it just the shortest route possible
under the river and be done with it at a
very high level philosophical View and
and the range of views expressed tonight
reflect the
is the competing forces at play that
seems to me what we need to get better
from the community and then if there is
hopefully a clear directive then you can
home in on the one preferred option and
if it's under the river that's under
River and away we go or if it's
a bridge over the river without any of
the Bells or missiles where you go and
in the interim hopefully his worship and
I will have a discussion with waikiketai
and the funding commitment or otherwise
will emerge and that could actually
again be highly influential as to which
option we choose but it seems to me that
we just need to get it out the community
and also in a format and
Sony can reinforce this that it's
comprehendable to most people in the
community and they can make an informed
Choice without being too simplified but
also a bereft of technical speak and
stuff that people might find hard to
engage with
Mackenzie
I'm into it today I just want to make a
comment um about upgrading
the plant up at Tilbury of I had a phone
call from a gentleman by the name of
Peter kempfield this morning now Matt
will probably know who Peter is
um Peter used to work for the council
and water services and I won't use the
language that he used
but he said to me what the Jolly G was
are they doing why don't they just
upgrade hilber Avenue but um I think he
would have just liked me to make that
comment so it's not necessarily mine but
I'm making that comment on his behalf
thank you
in light of moving this forward
the motion as I as I see fit and I'm
happy for it to be edited
um
is I think we push forward with
communicating
um
with the community community I would be
keen on doing a public meeting between
now and the next council meeting even if
it's only just me fronting the public
I'd love to hear the views of the
community as I seem to have been
convinced since the last couple of days
since the agenda's been published if
this could come back to the next council
meeting in terms of progress of where
we're at with Community engagement we
might get a resounding one way or the
other to keep the fire in this
conversation and keep us moving forward
is that the way we're hitting
can I get a move of that motion do that
make sense sorry
yes Susan
okay cool fantastic
do I have a mover for that motion
Council McKenzie my seconder
counselor MacDonald
do we have any further debate
uh councilor I'm going to counselor Reed
yep thank you I'd like to actually
ensure that our Communications officer
actually has the opportunity to
um go down a parallel path with this I
take I think councilor mcphail's point
about how with public meetings you often
get the most vocal who are quite
prepared to stand up and poor old Joe
blog sitting in the corner is not going
to do that whereas if you present them
with a different
um
of media to do it whatever which way it
is even if it's just filling in a survey
form they often you get a better picture
of the entire community so I really
strongly feel we need to have all of
those actions going forward
through the chair I suppose we need to
probably have a think about what you
want to present to the public I mean
we've got to have information created
we've got to get information from the
three Waters guys from Finance team in
terms of you know impact this might have
on people want to know what the impact's
going to have on them so they can make
that informed decision you've got to
realize where the need is going to need
to create some collateral that removes a
graphic designer and getting stuff put
together we have to contract that out
it's all time frames plus you've got a
lot of other stuff happening as well so
while it is a priority and totally will
be given priority in terms of my team or
me
um you know there are external parties
that I have to wait for as well to
provide information
uh it's yeah yeah counselor um I said
Mr Speaker just clarify the motion that
you're proposing as it is it the option
four with the three
the three prongs so it's basically the
recommendation we have in front of us
except your desire to have a public
meeting before we meet again
and table report come back to Council
next council meeting as to how they're
tracking with that with that engagement
yeah thank you
Council Havel
rather than a public meeting I'm
wondering if we adopt the approach that
environment Southland has used on some
of its
floodbank proposals where they've had a
drop in meeting so rather than having
everyone listening to someone talking
over a period of three hours or whatever
people have the opportunity of coming in
and talking one to one with people that
are in the room including staff elected
representatives and yourself I think
that would be a far more efficient
method and allows the quieter people to
actually Express a one-on-one View and
and we need to give some thought as to
how how that's recorded but I see that
as far more efficient
and In fairness to this report it is
included here as a drop-in sessions at
key locations with the conversation
Caravan uh my concern with that is as
Sonia alluded to the amount of material
that has to be produced for those
drop-in sessions
um the public meeting it is US showing
up in the public expressing their
concerns and asking us questions
um I feel like we're all pretty
knowledgeable around the table A Drop In
Session I expect is a bit more under
like you know you have the report here
and staff that can talk to it is the key
difference there
uh but we could yeah I mean we could
look at time frames for for drop-in
sessions
I guess
the drop-in session will be a lot like
the amp show where from the
conversations that met here it was it
was 50 50 at the end of the day and my
reluctance from doing this entire
process is we end up back in June with a
50 50 spot of the community and we're
still set here going what do we do next
that's that's why I'd like to bring to
the next meeting hopefully in the space
of a month we get you know there are
some very vocal people that I'm sure
will put together a very good argument
as to which way to go
and we will try our best to get in touch
with the less vocal people and that will
give us hopefully a better understanding
of where to move forward we've got to
make a decision on this guys we have to
keep moving it forward
do we have any further debate
no the motion is there all those in
favor please say aye
and against
and the motion is carried
thank you councilors let's move on
I'm just going to go back
um sorry I've just skipped over we're
going to go Point eleven I skipped over
it earlier when we were talking about
oh with a two-hour Mark should we have a
break
[Laughter]
if you want to break it sounds like
Keith might want to
thanks for that
so we'll pause for a five minute break
and then we'll come back
based on the fact that we were agreeing
to quarterly I'm assuming there isn't
much debate
um but are there any questions for our
government support
so we're at number 11.
74.
everyone happy with those dates
uh just for clarification Susan uh
obviously they start at May June
um did we already
lock the other ones in we do okay
so we don't need to confirm any of them
in here
um have I got a different sheet to you
no no
as long as they buy monthly I thank
everyone around the table trust that
they'll be booked in their calendars
accordingly
correct
and seventh seventh of March for audit
and risk
yeah and assets infrastructure
could I please have a mover that the
proposed meeting scheduled for the
standing committees for the remainder of
2023 be approved
for councilor hovel and seconded by
councilor Stringer
uh we'll put the motion all those in
favor please AI and against and the
motion is carried
over the next page to the Rural Road
subcommittee
so page 75.12
[Music]
did the chief executive want to add
anything to this report no fantastic
uh were there any questions for the
Chiefs that could have councilor
Phillips
just one thing you were so it would
probably be prudent do put initials in
mcfail to rectify that because do make
fails
and she
'll be noted thanks for that uh
councilor any other
councilor Hotel I I would envisage that
that subcommittee would then fall under
the assets and infrastructure committee
and I think that should be noted as part
of the
um
through you worship yeah we can just put
reports to
um the assets and infrastructure
committee
I know that it's been preempted that
there's an agenda out already for it
fantastic we are fast moving here and
some aspects which is great to see
uh do I have a mover for the motion that
the council approved the establishment
of the Rural Road subcommittee together
with the terms of reference as profiled
in appendix B attached to this report
with that change added to it uh
councilor guard iron and seconded by
councilor mcfail
I will put the motion all those in favor
please say aye and against the motion is
carried
now flipping right to the back
to page 17 ah sorry 170 uh 0.70 the
adoption of the annual report
did the report rise to lornay want to
add anything uh to this
uh through your worship I think it's
throughout relatively self-explanatory
for people who who know numbers I mean
the key parts are that we treat given
the given the year that we've had with
covert um with inflationary pressures uh
Staffing shortages the council's done
actually pretty pretty well in
considering considering that the key
difference between the Surplus and
um well what what the what the surface
was and what we ended up with compared
to budget the main differences they are
actually related to Grants and the
timing of Grants so if we strip out the
grants then we get we're pretty much
being on track of where we anticipate be
there's always ups and downs within
different activities but on the whole we
we have we have performed reasonably
well in the in the circumstances
um
what we'll find this year so so sort of
looking forward to what what's happening
you know we we did uh because a few of
our periodies were behind uh where we
had planned them to be we didn't borrow
as much as we had intended this will
Rectify in the current year so a lot of
those projects are well up and running
and almost finished so we will be at the
end of the end of the 20 to 30 22-23
year we will be close to to what we had
anticipated in our annual plan
so yeah I think I think I'm happy to
take questions if if counselors want to
want to ask some questions
are there any questions for lornay on
this report
counselor
question but I'd just like to
congratulate Lorna and the team members
and know you're down one again now so um
but it's been a really hard slog and I
appreciate all the extra time and effort
that you've put on and with the rest of
the team over the last 12 months to get
to the stage
well done
thank you for that councilor um were
there any other questions around the
table
uh I actually have a question of my own
um Lorna just in the grants
um just being new to the council
um the hook and we're here to seem to
trust
um that's the main Grant where there's
discrepancies between the annual plan
and the actual I was just wondering what
that was related to I couldn't see any
notes on it and that might be done to me
not really properly but
no
um through your worship the previous
Council throughout the year there was
various members that came up to council
for additional funding for the hokanoi
Heritage Museum and and they were
approved through Council so it's gone
through the appropriate channels for
being approved and that's just reflected
in there
thank you for that
any further questions
read your microphone song
apology that's all right
anyone else
uh Council guard on
you'll notice the um the swaps made
quite a contribution towards the actual
profit is that sort of just a paper
figure and it sort of comes and goes
uh he's through your ship yes swaps are
one of those interesting things that um
our fair weather friends or or not um
they
they don't get fully realized until they
come to maturity so every year depending
on what the markets are doing and what
the economy is doing
um they will they will move accordingly
with interest rates moving up that means
on the positive side we we ended up with
a more positive result this year so Nick
this year was 163k and last year was a
negative 100 1.4 million so again it's
it's all about timing we do have some of
those maturing in the near future so
um we'll we'll see what what happens
with when we actually realize them
any further questions specifically for
Lorne before we get into General debate
okay
where's the recommendation
do we have a mover that the report we
received at the annual report for the
year ended 30 June 2022 be adopted and
that the chief executive be empowered to
make topographical and layout changes
necessary for publishing the document
uh councilor Reed seconded by
councilor Phillips
and now it's open for debate or comment
I guess to to open it up
um
coming as a new counselor
um and ultimately pretty close to member
of public I I find this hard to to read
and that's no detriment to the staff
that prepared it beautifully but I think
it's a conversation we need to have at a
governance level about the level of
reporting more so into next year I think
for this year you know that need to be
done but to help us better understand
um just kind of where we're tracking I
know that um
the legislative obligations is to
provide the ltp summaries in here but
comparing these to actuals and in other
years um they're quite different to what
was proposed in the ltp and I think
that's relevant when reading this
document as a counselor I I find it
confusing
um and I'm sure other councilors will
talk to you later have things explained
once again not the fault of of the staff
but but ultimately I think it's
something we need to look into for
future annual reports and in the way
that they're structured
um
and ultimately making sure that that our
staff can can hit their targets because
there is a lot of not achieves across
the board and I understand there was
external factors but
um ultimately we want to be able to for
our staff to achieve their goals
um those my two cents um from reading
the report
um I don't know if that starts the
debate uh lunae I'd love to hear your
comments
think of your worship these um documents
are very prescriptive very legislative
and we have very little wiggle room into
changing anything with them they are set
down by the oag and by the New Zealand
chart of child accountants so we there's
very little room there can be more
narrative when you're talking referring
to the statement of service performance
and not achieves they are they are part
of the ltp and they are service
performance measures or performance
measures compared to last year we have
improved like last year overall we had
62 this year we're up around 67 I
believe so there is improvements being
made and a lot of those are Beyond air
control one I'd like to point out in
particular or two I'd like to point out
uh to do with water and it was through
no fault of staff that we missed those
measures the lab did not pick up the
testing results so it mean we failed
because they didn't pick up one testing
result in time with the other ones we're
working towards protozoa and the New
Zealand drinking water standards and
that's all to do with the bridge so five
of those measures that we missed are
related to water and not
anything that was an air control at the
moment so I just wanted to clarify that
for people who may be listening and for
elected members and I'm happy to sit
with any elector member at any time and
talk through what what the results mean
thank you very much that Lorna that
provides um an extreme amount of clarity
so thank you very much uh councilor
mcfar
through your worship and regard to those
performance measures
they were subject of previous discussion
at Council I think it was
two years ago when we actually did have
a workshop and working group that worked
with yourself around setting them
because it was the same discussion
regarding where we where we sit in
targets that were unachievable so they
were placed under scrutiny a couple of
years ago so
I do agree with what lornay is saying
they have had
have had a bit of figure and um
have been chased around a bit
sorry just the clarification do you
think that process may need to be done
again or are we happy with kind of where
we were at it's better curiosity part of
the RTP okay called fantastic thank you
for that
do we have any other comments around the
annual report councilor Dixon
now is that funding come through because
I see there was a shortfall there
um through your worship it wasn't a
shortfall so in the expenditure are we
it's inviting incoming at the
expenditure but because it's a grant
that's awarded every year has to be
applied for so at the time of going to
annual plan we could not put it in as an
anticipated income or expenditure so
their project Nets itself off overall so
we're given 500 000 each year or for the
last few years we've been given five
hundred thousand dollars what we spend
of it
um gets set off against that and any
short any underspins gets sent back to
BMB thank you and just wondering about
the additional costs for the district
plan are they additional costs because I
see their 527
um or are they included in because we
had to rush through some of the district
plans so is it going to end up at the
end being the same cost or more
through your worship District plan
there's a couple of contributing factors
there so it's a multi-year project and
in some years previously we've been
lower than had budget spent lower than
what we had budgeted and in this year we
spent more there was a decision made to
accelerate the district plan to get it
out for submission and notification
earlier so it has been front loaded into
into this year so there's budgets set in
for 22 23 that will not be that there
may not be spent
any further comments questions
Etc
Council Australia
uh you're just on the performance
measures these democracy and and
administration
um zero percent achieved what's the um
what's the failing on that
three-way ship that measure is based on
our residence satisfaction survey and
it's based on elected members uh
satisfaction with elector members
performance
so it is purely based on that
no pressure uh
uh any further questions
no further questions around the table
I will put the motion uh all those in
favor please say aye
and those against
the motion has been carried
yay now onto the easy stuff
well should be
let's go for let's bring it right back
to the start
um so we are now just following the
order that they fall on
this ring of Staff warrants in
authorization this one is pretty
straightforward in my opinion uh did we
have any questions for the titties that
could have won this one
nope uh
can I please have a mover that the
council appoint and authorize Bridget
and Sim to undertake various enforcement
related duties in accordance with the
Local Government Act 2002 and the
resource management act 1991. councilor
hotel seconded by councilor Dixon
any debates all those in favor please
say aye
against the motion is carried
in your report on dog control to the
Chiefs that you want to speak to this
report at all
and not particularly your worship it
look it's it's an annual report that we
must compile uh it's useful it gives a
statistical breakdown and highlights
issues that occurred in the previous
year under review
it's a difficult area of the council's
operations where
you get 95 of dog owners or more who
have no issues and there's a very small
percentage
consume a lot of time and attention
so if there any questions I'll achieve
regarding this report
could I please have a mover that
pursuant to section 10A of the Dog
Control Act 1996 the gore District
Council report on dog policy and
practices for the 20 21 2022 be adopted
uh mover cancer Guardian seconded by
Council of Richard mcfail
the only thing I have to add there is a
apologies to the public around the delay
in this report some members of the
public expect it uh late last year
that's been due to mainly staff illness
and yeah so apologies for that but
otherwise I will put the motion
uh all those in favor please say aye and
against the motion is carried
draft trainal agreement uh for the
Southland region uh to the chief you
want to comment on this one at all
I think that's pretty self-explanatory
you worship uh it's um it's a statutory
obligation we have to have one place by
one match generally uh it's put to one
side and is not
um frequently referred to throughout the
course of the term but we use the
opportunity to update it and for example
the funding of the South Memorial Forum
advisor is in there but uh pretty
non-controversial and has been
workshopped by Chief Executives and the
Merrell Forum before it gets to you
today
yes there's a further that from the
chief executive
um there was some robust debate around
the table
um specifically around the joint
shareholders committee for Great South
uh that wasn't being used there that was
kind of being sidestepped and bring
brought straight to mural forms to make
decisions on Great South
um namely because the
sheer the A-Plus shareholders set on
Merrell forms there's no point bring it
to a separate committee when they had
voting power anyway so we've scrapped
that to involve the Beast shareholders
as well so it now comes to the
subcommittee that it was assigned to
um
John Garden was actually representative
on there I don't know if he even knew
that he was involved because he never
met but
um that's beside the point uh
oh cool that's awesome
um but I think it's taken a lot more of
a mayoral approach to um this there's
some stuff going on with
um great stuff which I can share a
little bit about later on
uh moving on can I have a move for the
recommendation that the council approved
the attach training or agreement for the
Southland region pertaining to the
period of October 2022 through to
October 2025 and authorized the mere and
chief executive sign on the council's
behalf moved by councilor Reed seconded
by
councilor Paul mcphail
do we have any debate on the table
Council guardine
it's my yeah it's a separate process so
it's a process that comes that
subcommittee um we're ultimately Great
South comes to us with how much funding
they're going to need and there's a bit
of back and forth which we're in the
process of at the moment I'm finalizing
um what those numbers look like
um to summarize it great self has asked
for significantly more money and as
you're well aware most councils don't
have any more money to give at the
moment so um
back and forth and it's a yearly process
councilor Stringer
uh yeah just on the sharing of resources
understanding that we're understaffed in
some areas are we utilizing some of
their resources for our benefit
yeah so I'll let the chief executive and
possibly reiterate a bit more but it
isn't the annual report in terms of some
of the shared services as well
um yeah so that's a clear test to look
but I don't know if you have further
comment this too
yeah a good question that we do
um and some of the some of the some
really like Emergency Management
Southland was a classic case that's a
shared service that we've put in place
10 years ago and probably is seen as one
of the leading lights in the country of
how to deliver a shared service to a
higher level
um and for the broader Council point of
view you know we only had a back in the
day a one part-time officer we've now
got access to a a pool of professionals
there's quite a lot of collaboration
um but it's fair to say the the
low-hagging fruit has been picked
um and there's a good collaboration at
second tier level amongst planning staff
through water staff
but there's also sometimes there's times
where one organization might be Keen to
share a service
and doesn't suit another so for example
one area that has been been about is
building control
but we've unfortunately our building
control is a good unit we've we've
managed to fill our vacancies
uh and we deliver a service in a compact
District so it's a different type of
service that would be offered say in our
neighbor say southern district we're
very much far flung so it does tend to
be horses for courses but we're possible
we do share and certainly Southland
there's a really good level of
collaboration at chief executive level
as there is a mirror level to talk about
opportunities
and ultimately if there is a lot of
feeling around the council table of
looking into like a review of that it's
something that can be brought to Merrell
form to see if there's uptake from other
Mayors as well just to look into that um
to see if there are any other
low-hanging fruit that may have been
missed but from my perspective I'm
pretty confident from what I've seen
that there are some really decent huge
services
do we have any further comment
uh Council Garden
what points are on here
so this is this is us this is us paying
for the support person
um so her name is Megan um she does a
fantastic job
um so she sits um under ICC but we all
contribute towards her salary
um for the support of of these
committees
yeah so she she also does like um the
same role as Susan for the Great South
um subcommittee here yeah
just one position
any further comments
no I will put the motion all those in
favor please say aye
and against the motion is carried
item 13 yep page 80.
buy some team
I believe it does yes
my apologies Council that's going well
over my head um did you have a comment
on that Steve
yeah um thanks you worship I've standed
created by Susan Jones but I think Keith
councilor halvale was right that that a
specific so you've you've you've passed
a resolution my memory
uh as you've passed a resolution on that
the membership of the Committees will be
eight members strong
um and that the they'll be meeting
quarterly that the council will uh
approve any subcommittee but once
approved a subcommittee will report back
to the standing committee I don't think
you did we did resolve the issue of
those missing parts of the policy and
planning committee which is a regulatory
Services functions it would be if if
that if my recollection is correct
incision group of wrong it would be an
easy fix to pass a motion that the
policy and planning committee uh terms
of reference include oversight of the
council's regulatory functions in terms
of a name naming on the hoof is not a
not recommended maybe the committee
should meet and if it's to satisfy with
its name they can come up with another
one and recommend back to full Council
so we'll put that as a motion yep do we
have a second do we have a second to
count cigar iron uh any debate
all those in favor please say aye
and against
thank you for that the motion is carried
just that key
now back to 0.13 page AC
I will Rick said you want to speak to
this one or would you like me to let
yeah councilors uh Council I know that's
both Keith and glennis have been working
on this do they have any comments they
wanted to add to this
awesome
uh Council Dixon
thank you worship I just have a few
comments to make about some of the some
of the
process that isn't um particularly well
thought through like the lack of clarity
in terms of definition
the exclusion of the local voice in
particular because there seems to be a
centralization of control here and the
power once again is taken from local
communities so the um
in in my view I think submission is is
very good and covers all those points
but there's there is there's a lack of
clarity in the whole
process and I'm not particularly pleased
with the way the Irma is going to change
if it changes this way and I also note
the people on the select committee are
all list members none of them are
actually
pointed MPS so do they understand that
local input is is very important in this
process it's just my comment
thanks for that counselor and it and it
seems like there is a trend with these
reforms that are coming down that the
process isn't being well thought of um
and it's leading up to local government
to kind of hold the burden on that one
in particular
um but I know the same sets of three
Waters and future for local government
um that's been proposed we have to deal
with it but how we deal with it is not
being clarified whatsoever councilor
Havel did you want to speak at all
the the draft submissions in the agenda
I don't want to add any further time but
I'm happy to answer any questions people
might have
thank you for that counselor uh do I
have a mover that the report be received
the council approved with any agreed
amendments the draft Gore District
Council submission natural and built
environment Bill and special planning
Bill and that the council requests the
right to speak to its submission at the
environment select committee and
delegates this responsibility to Deputy
Mia councilor Keith hovel and the chief
executive moved by councilor Guardian
seconded by councilor Richard mcfail do
we have any further debates
thank you
thanks there councilor councilman fan
yes I was just uh and uh signaling that
I think are the most appropriate uh
councilor Dixon with her
um resource commissioner or training
background and obviously councilor hoval
with his um extensive background and
this sort of thing I think it's quite
appropriate that we give them a
delegation to speak on behalf of the
gore Council
and I would tend to agree on my
gratitude to both the councils involved
with this um it is one less reform that
I have to bear the brunt of so I really
appreciate the hard work that's been put
in uh and I look forward to hearing how
um the speak at the environment slick
committee goes uh councilor over may I
just acknowledge the input that the
staff has had which is probably greater
than what the elect representatives have
put in and it's greatly appreciated
thank you
sorry who are that no just straight yes
thank you to the staff as well um for
the hard work that they've put in on
this one I really appreciate it as well
I will put the motion all those in favor
please say aye and then against
the motion is carried
moving on I
so now we uh
I think we're at the
that is correct
so this is the minutes for the matoda
community board
um I believe in the first set of minutes
there
isn't a whole lot that they asked about
which is quite nice
uh so do I do we have any questions
um on those minutes in particular the
first set
so the matoto community board on the
Monday the 12th of December
nothing can I have a mover that those
minutes are true and correct oh no not
that the strung Creek that we receive
them
uh councilor Phillips seconded by
councilor Stringer any debate on those
minutes in particular
no all those in favor please say aye
and against the motion is carried now
for Monday the 30th of January 2023 I
believe there are some
points that we do need to discuss
could I also please make a note to the
government support that we have these
pulled out so that we don't have to look
through the minutes um because there are
quite a few recommendations just to make
it easier in the future if that's okay
just some of these points that we have
to discuss
um to the spirit and the menopause
that's all
um so the first being the meeting dates
for 2023
um so they're looking at a meeting
schedule uh the combined meetings so
Tuesday the 4th of April uh and Monday
the 21st of August the recommendation
from the community board was that we had
our council meeting combined with theirs
done in matoda
um so we just have to rectify that we're
all comfortable with that uh
The Proposal is that we have at joint
meeting so we have the the Voting Rights
but they are there involved in the
discussion
um that we have but it is it is a
regular council meeting from my
understanding
do we have any issues with having that
council meeting at 5 30 in matoda on the
21st of August
no issues
uh okay uh can I have a
can I have a move for the motion
um that we expect we accept
uh these two joint meetings
and lock them in Council Stringer to
move it and
councilor mcdonell to Second it's
uh he needs a base around that one in
particular
nope all those in favor please say aye
and against the motion is carried
uh the next Point
um if you go to page 160 and the
recommendation uh run the state highway
signs
um I just wanted to give a bit of an
update for councilors around that item
and also for the community board present
so Murray has gone ahead and chased up
the construction of those signs
apparently he is to get images of what
has been done so far tomorrow and that
will be forwarded on to counselors and
also the community board but my
understanding that he is happy with the
progress so we are starting to get
somewhere which I'm sure the Matilda
community board will be very pleased
with
but that is just a note
uh I don't believe we have Keith here I
was just wondering whether we could
does anyone maybe Jason know whether
that report that is coming back to
council
um compiled about the rubbish bins
um how that's progressing or maybe when
it might be presented to council so
we're looking at page 162 just towards
the bottom there at the recommendation
yes
foundations want to be ratified the
instructions will be given to the staff
to progress the report
okay fantastic so we don't need to
specifically pull these out
to the council
so once Council verifies the minutes
the recommendations on board will be
um actually okay
the list is
um
yes okay that's cool
I'm happy with the recommendations
somewhere
I guess I what I just wanted to do was
point out some of the more controversial
um points that were made so that
councilors are aware of it rather than
just
um
following through the minutes and then
we don't really know what we've agreed
to
um so it's just making people aware
um which is called I just didn't know
the process the other one is that we're
happy to have the Minnesota community
board instruct staff
um to con to obtain estimates of the
cost of a full and partial clean of the
matoda river Brew bridge over the matoto
river
and approaching what kotahi to paint the
approach sign rails covered under
graffiti is there any conversation
around it in particular councilor Reed
that's two different Bridges we're
talking about isn't it
uh yes there is um but namely that first
recommendation which will be a
significant amount of work done to get a
cost for a full and partial clean of the
bridge
is it a place as a council to be
interfering in waikatoi's job and asking
our staff to be doing that
sorry just for just a question for the
chief executive
you worship the answer is yes
etai are not doing the job and and it's
an asset that is not being
adequately maintained or is causing some
concern about its unsightedness so the
answer is in principle yes and in the
past we've done that with whakatahi kiwi
rail
um where perhaps lack of Maintenance has
um given cause for concerning the
community
so in the minutes just to give
clarification on the the meeting I'm
sure Neville can elaborate If he if he
likes but
um in the past what could I he has
helped clean the bridge or fun cleaning
the bridge they've decided they're not
going to do that um in the Matilda
community board want to take it on
themselves to at least get a costing for
what that may cost them
um to clean that bridge because uh it's
it's causing an issue in their community
those were all the points that I just
wanted to pull out Neville go for it the
thing you wrote um
while while I agree to disagree on on
this aspect is that I know what the
community board at heart want the bridge
cleaned and
they can only see the way is to spend
their own money
but us as a council
should not let them spend their own
money we should be putting pressure on
makatawi to clean the bridge
we should be standing there with
placards of POS if necessary now why
should
the small commitmentaric community board
try and get it fund the cleaning of the
bridge you know and I don't believe that
they realize how much it is they're
going to actually cost it's going to
cost a lot of money because they're
going to it's going to full scaffolding
full traffic management
Etc carry on and Etc so
I think as a council
we should back them 100 percent
and say put the pressure on wakato you
say look this is a disgrace it's a
disgrace to my town it's a entrance to
our town coming in from State Highway
it's your responsibility ability to make
sure it's cleaned
and then put the pressure on the inner
side and to do it
um look if it's if it means media well
it means media you know
I don't know I think that's what we
should be doing
well counselor
um and to further that point when the uh
wakatahi representative uh comes down I
have scheduled some time to take him
over the intersection and Matilda
um that is desperately in need of repair
um and also while we're there we will
probably also look at the bridge as well
so I can once we've had that trip report
back and if there's further action
needed from a from a high power then it
may be necessary yeah thank you you
worship but there is two bridges in
material
one that comes over State Highway 93 and
one that goes on State Highway One both
those bridges need cleaned and tidied
and both the waikatoi's responsibility
agreed yeah and um I will make that sure
that point is um
portrayed across to the representative
were there anything else in these
minutes that's um any councils would
like to bring to the attention of the
full Council
did Nikki have any comment you're okay
cool
uh so could I please have a movie that's
um the recommendations within these ones
be uh sorry in the minutes for the
Monday 30th January 2023 uh are ratified
as they are
could a piece of a mover for that motion
uh councilor Phillips secondary by
Council
and Council valve for the second all
doesn't say the police say aye
and against the motion is carried
we moved to 167.16
rural travel funds
did uh councilor next to now want to
speak to this at all
very easy meeting we had had only two
applications and we had the money as you
see we gave the Kingsford softball Club
fifteen hundred dollars in Saint Peter's
cricket team their Fuller allocation
so that that was it was very quick and
easy
thanks for that counselor uh
could I please get a mover that these
minutes I've received and noted Council
make Danelle for the Mover and seconder
councilor Dixon uh all those in favor
please say aye
and against the motion is carried could
I just also make a note
um namely to the cheesy curve that maybe
these sorts of minutes can come to one
of the Committees rather than full
Council thank you for that
yeah we are at
7.18 look at us match the end I don't
think we'd get there
um so South America Forum
um is there any questions I'm happy you
don't answer any questions from that
mail from that um electors may have I
can give a bit of a bit of a rundown if
you want as well
so I think it's probably key to
um talk about some of the subjects on
here so the Dunedin Hospital has been
one of hot debates
and there hasn't been a whole lot of
unity across the board we all agree that
the cut shouldn't happen but mounting a
directive to the minister has proven
difficult to say the least
um
the gore District at this moment has
through me because I've been involved in
it a lot has taken a step back I have no
interest in threatening the minister at
this stage and have tried to work
through other solutions that haven't
particularly gone anywhere so at the
protection of our hospital and our
locality at this moment we're not much
in the streets on this one but fully
support my colleague or our colleague um